jean-pierre approached the mystery of
the Great Pyramid with an architect's
eye working from the most detailed
architectural plans ever drawn of the
Great Pyramid slowly his theory began to
evolve as the years passed unnoticed by
Egyptologists he came to know the my new
details of the pyramid like no one else
on earth the $64,000 question is how do
you raise blocks all the way to the top
of a four hundred and eighty foot
pyramid we saw that there were real
problems with either a single ramp or a
spiral ramp and lifting cranes certainly
don't do the job so how do you do it
that's the problem John Pierre has been
tackling for all these years
his solution still has around but it's
inside the pyramid and incredibly
according to Jean Pierre it's been
hidden there for 4,500 years he
calculated that the slope of this ramp
had to be about 7% so the men could hole
the blocks up it he also figured the
ramp would have to start at the base of
the pyramid and go upwards as the
pyramid grew it's not as easy as it
sounds
remember the pyramid is not solid inside
the Great Pyramid are three large
chambers the lowest one is called the
Queen's Chamber
above it is a mysterious room called the
Grand Gallery and on top of all that is
the Kings burial chamber all three
chambers are connected by passageways is
it possible to have a ramp snaking up
through the pyramid that doesn't run
into one of these chambers or
passageways
as he began building his computer model
he could see the ramp just ten feet
inside the smooth outer surface of the
pyramid turning level after level all
the way to the top of the pyramid kind
of like a ramp in a parking garage
amazingly jean-pierre ramp never hit any
of the chambers of passageways inside
the Great Pyramid for the first time in
history a structural 3d model of the
Great Pyramid had been built to test a
theory jean-pierre knew the internal
ramp was a real possibility but he still
had problems to solve how to turn the
blocks around the corners of the ramp
you see the men hauling the blocks need
a place to stand in front of the blocks
when they reached the end of the
straightaway on the ramp where can they
stand to pull the block jean-pierre
solution is to leave the corners open at
the end of each length of the ramp a
notch about 30 feet square would have
been left open this notch let in light
and fresh air but it had an even more
important function
stationed at each corner was a crane
that would lift and position the block
so it could travel up the next flight of
the ramp these cranes could be the
machines that Herodotus was talking
about but like any good detective story
we've been saving the best for last
if jean-pierre is right about the
internal ramp the French team should
have detected it in their 1980s hi-tech
survey in the French team's published
report there is no diagram of an
internal ramp
it looks like jean-pierre is wrong
surely a study this sophisticated would
have found evidence of something as
large as an internal ramp but 15 years
after the study jean-pierre was asked to
meet a member of the French team who
said he had some very good news for him
dr. bleep had heard about John PS theory
and wanted to show him something a
diagram that the French didn't fully
understand so they never published it
Wow
see Takayama this computer print death
shows a low-density spiral shape inside
the Great Pyramid it's amazingly close
to Jean Pia's drawing of the internal
ramp so years before Jean Pierre's
theory the French may have found
evidence of an internal ramp inside the
Great Pyramid